- Number one.
- Aw, thank you!
I love you, Gladys Grandma.
- Me too.
(upbeat music)
(Buzzfeed signature sound)
- I'm from Santa Maria, California,
and I am Mexican and Irish.
- I was born in Havana, Cuba.
- Oh.
- You're cheap.
Because you're cheap.
- Not cheap.
- She's looking in the
mirror, but she's like,
"(sighs) I'm getting old.
"My skin-- (sighs)"
- She doesn't really talk
about herself a lot (laughs).
She talks about other people.
She'll be like, "Remember Margarita?
"Margarita. You don't know Margarita?"
(frustrated sounds)
(laughter)
- Ah, no?
- Sierra, you can talk to me.
What are you doing?
Where are you?
- I can't talk.
I'm busy.
I'll call you later!
Click. (laughs)
- Don't tell me you're busy!
(exasperated sigh)
- I call her again.
(laughter)
- Did you see what Margarita put
on her Facebook yesterday as her status?
- Mom, who's Margarita?
- Margarita, Jenny!
Margarita, the girl who
went to your graduation,
and she (high speed chipmunk voice)
- Nope, I don't know who she is, Mom.
- What'd you eat?
(laughs)
- One time is enough!
(relaxed dance music)
(laughs)
- This is Sierra.
- That's right. (laughs)
- Boom, boom, boom.
That's how I dance.
- She goes like this, and
like this, and all around.
- I'm a hula dancer?
- Oh, gang signs!
(laughter)
- All right, I'm gonna go now.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Love you.
- [Jenny] Bye.
- [Mercy] Bye.
- I love you, Mom!
Bye!
- I don't say it like that!
- Yeah, you do.
- No I don't!
- That's true.
- She's like the sister that I never had.
- She's like, yeah.
- And my little daughter, and my first.
- My grandmother is everything to me.
She's my world.
We have a really close relationship,
but especially now that she
can email me and Facebook me.
- She was really young when she had me.
- I'm still young. (laughs)
- She would be like,
um, "You're not allowed
"to play with Barbies, but
your mom gets out at 5:00,
"so put the Barbies away at 3:00."
But I would play with Barbies
and put makeup on her and do her hair.
- Yeah.
Ew, I'm crying!
(upbeat music)
(Buzzfeed signature sound)